[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you
so this talk is about druid it's really
about the history of this project why we
decided to build a database it talks
about the various trade offs of the
system and kind of how the architecture
of the system works as a whole before I
kind of jump into the talk I was just
wondering how many people have actually
heard of this project before okay cool
yeah it's great that a bunch of folks
have have talked about it if you haven't
heard of this project before the way
that druid has been described I guess on
its web page is it's a high-performance
column-oriented distributed data store
and if you're anything like me that last
sentence probably didn't make a whole
lot of sense because this is filled with
buzzwords some are try and and break
apart what this project is about and
sort of the trade-offs and purpose of
the project so if we peel apart the
buzzwords of druids tagline when we say
druid is high performance we mean this
is this is a system that is really
designed for very low latency queries so
for the vast majority of queries that we
target they tend to be sub-second when
we say the system is column-oriented
what that just means is data is stored
in a column orientation now go with a
little bit more detail about what that
means this system is distributed which
just means that if you a whole lot of
data that's okay because it runs on a
whole bunch of servers and this project
is a datastore so there's a copy of your
data within druid
so druid is open source and a question
we always get asked whenever we talk
about this system is you know why did
you build it why did you build your own
system and I really like this quote from
a Twitter account that unfortunately I
think I stopped tweeting it's called
DevOps Borat and it says in startup we
have great enough capacity for turnout
solution please send problem we pay good
money and it's just a reminder that when
you build system so you really shouldn't
build them unless you have a problem at
hand you know as engineers we oftentimes
just want to build systems because it's
cool to build systems but
really when you build a system you
should have some sort of problem that
you're trying to solve so when we
started built building through it we had
a problem really around this idea of
being able to do interactive exploration
of data so we had a lot of data and what
we mean by a lot of data is around a few
million events per second and the whole
data set might be petabytes of data as a
whole and we were trying to build an
application where people could slice and
dice and run various types of
aggregations on top of that data so be
able to view the data from many
different lens and access and get
insights through an application so the
whole flow would be interactive we
wanted everyone to use that application
and be able to look under the hood of
different types of reports and
dashboards and on top of this very large
data set we wanted not only to do
historical analysis but also be able to
look at events as they were happening so
we wanted fresh updates in our data so
when you're working with very large
event sets when you're working with very
large activity streams there's a whole
range of technical challenges you have
to solve one is data can be very high in
dimensionality so you can not you know
Wikipedia is a very simple data set
there's only ten columns or so but you
can have data sets that have tens or
hundreds or even thousands of columns
and the number of unique values in those
columns could be millions or tens of
millions or even hundreds of millions so
handling high dimensionality data does
require a lot of thought in order to
make the queries fast ad-hoc analysis is
also a very difficult challenge
obviously one way of just making queries
really fast is to pre-compute out and
just cache every query you think your
users can make however as your data gets
really too difficult or too complex it
becomes too difficult to pre-compute
every possible query that a user can
make with any sort of application or any
sort of widely used system multi-tenancy
is a problem so you can have
actually thousands of concurrent users
hitting the same data set at the same
time another difficulty is to surround
streaming data and around data freshness
so the ability to ingest a stream of
data and then provide insights on events
as soon as they're occurring the last
challenge we're working with some of
these types of data sets is just really
around scale some activity streams can
be brilliant events per second and even
though every single event is a very low
value you can't really sample the data
because if you have something like a
revenue stream your sap will be way off
of of a stream that needs to have an
exact number at the end so another kind
of question we get asked of like why did
you build your own database is there's
so many alternatives out there like why
not just use one of these other systems
to solve these types of problems and the
thing is we actually tried a whole bunch
of different types of systems before we
started working on Druid and I just
wanted to briefly talk about some of the
various trade-offs with with some
various systems so the first class of
systems I want to talk about are like
relational databases this is your
traditional data warehouse you can use
this for basically any type of data you
have out there and within this classes
of systems you have things like my
sequel and Postgres and many other many
other already are dbmss as well in a
relational database you basically have
your data kind of modeled in a row
orientation and a very common model that
you see with relational databases is
something called a star schema in the
idea of a star schema is you have the
central fact table which is basically
your raw data and a lot of your
measurements and then you have these
dimension tables off to the side which
describe in more detail some of the
various dimensions you have in your
central fact table people have been
using this for say decades at this point
they have tried various methods to try
and make queries fast such as creating
specialized aggregate tables or generate
query caching
from what I see of a lot of sort of more
modern data engineering in a lot of
different companies
this model is starting to become
outdated and the reason it's becoming
outdated is for very high volumes of
data relational databases are simply too
slow the next class of systems that's a
lot more popular nowadays it's been
popular for a little while our key value
stores so systems that belong here are
things like HBase or Cassandra we're
fundamentally they have a key value
storage model the kind of nice thing
about key value stores is you can do
very fast writes and you do very fast
look ups you know if you can do an o1
lookup based on a primary key get data
back really fast and there's a lot of
time series databases that often have a
key value storage engine so the way that
key value stores work the way you use
them for analytics and the way you use
them for queries is one of two ways
basically the first is something called
pre-computation this was popular maybe
about five years ago I think is trying
to become less and less popular now the
idea of pre-computation is a tape you
have some raw data set here you have a
timestamp column you have two dimensions
gender and age and then you have this
revenue metric that you want to
aggregate what you do with the pre
computation model is for basically every
permutation of queries that you can
think of you create a key that map's the
parameters of that query so if you
wanted to know you know how much revenue
is generated when time stamp equals one
you have this primary key where time
stamp equals one and revenue is the sum
of these three rows here if you wanted
to know hey how much revenue is
generated for time stamp one and gender
female the revenue is the sum of these
two rows here and you do this for
basically every permutation of queries
you can think of and your queries are
going to be really really fast you're
just doing a lookup into a map
for your query parameters you can get a
results results back right away the kind
of downside of doing this and there's
still a lot of companies that do do this
is that when the number of dimensions
where number of attributes your data
starts increasing your query space is
going to grow exponentially in size and
we were actually trying this with HBase
back in the day based on work that
Twitter was doing at that time but what
we found was it just became really
computationally intractable to try and
pre compute out every single query
because our data size has kept getting
more and more complex so pre-computation
I wouldn't really recommend it another
thing that people do do with key value
stores like like Cassandra and HBase and
then others is something more of a range
scan and the idea here is that your
primary key is basically a hash of your
timestamp and also your dimensions so
and then your value is sort of the exact
value you want to aggregate and then
when you issue a query for some time
range filtered on a set of things you
basically do a lookup into a primary key
and you do a range scan and you
aggregate the values that match together
the problem with this approach is also
really around performance one is if you
have a query that's filtered a lot of
different parameters if you're just
really slicing and dicing your data it
can be difficult to do a filter on your
primary key that exactly matches the
parameters of your query the other
problem is there is a separation between
where data is stored and where numbers
are ultimately crunched what that means
is basically basically every time you
issue a query a whole lot of data is
going to get shuffled around and loaded
into some place where results are
actually aggregated and then returned to
a user and this can also be very very
slow as well especially at scale
so key value stores for lower data
volumes I've seen people still use them
there's a lot of key value stores which
are extremely popular systems today at
higher scales start seeing a little bit
less as that's when people really start
facing problems another class of systems
that is I think pretty popular and they
have a lot of benefits and trade offs is
more sequel Hadoop solutions so these
solutions they basically enable ad hoc
queries on a whole lot of different
types of input formats so press though
and high spark sequel Impala and many
others I'm kind of generally bucketing
in this category the way that a system
like presto works is it's extremely
flexible and that it can handle a wide
variety of different queries and it does
that by basically pulling data from
where it lives whether that's in a
database or a filesystem into it's like
compute resources which are basically a
dedicated set of servers and within
those servers the results around get
crunched and then a result is returned
to the caller and this is very flexible
because it allows you to load data
really from anywhere you can do all
sorts of computations full sequel
supported before results are returned to
a caller the trade-off is really these
these arrows here can introduce
non-trivial overhead and cause
performance performance on the patients
so you might be wondering like why do I
keep bringing up performance if you're
building some sort of interactive
application if you do want users to be
able to flexibility and arbitrarily be
able to explore their data performance
does become important because when
you're interacting with data and if
every interaction takes a few minutes or
even 30 seconds to complete it's very
easy to lose a user so with a lot of
these systems I think a big trade-off is
really just around performance and the
ability to power sort of a user facing
application
so we were going through this exercise
before we started building through it
and we went through a whole bunch of
different systems all the ones I talked
about there and we looked at the
architecture of another class of systems
called column stars and in column stores
the primary difference with relational
database is your data is going to be
stored individually in columns and when
you issue a query only the columns that
pertain to that query are going to be
used as part of that query for different
types of columns you can have various
compression algorithms you can have
various indexes get created and I think
in the sort of more enterprise world a
lot of the more enterprise solutions
have all been based around column stores
when we started out looking at column
stores we obviously couldn't afford a
lot of the more enterprise solutions and
we started looking for an open-source
version and realized there wasn't really
a very good open source column store and
that's what led to Druitt so that was a
lot of preamble a lot of history a lot
of comparisons against a lot of
different systems that ultimately led to
us building Druid and drew it is an open
source column store it is really
designed for a couple of different
things it's designed for streaming data
ingestion so you can have very low
latency ingestion from Kafka and Samsa
and slink and many other sort of
streaming systems it's designed for low
latency ad hoc queries so every query
that's issued to Druitt is designed to
be completed in less than second Drude
supports exact approximately approximate
algorithms for some of the more complex
analytic flows that it does druid does
leverage approximation algorithms in
order for the queries to complete very
quickly drew can keep a lot of history
it can do years of data I can also do
streaming exact data and if you take all
these features card together you have a
system that's I think very good for
powering interactive applications
so second half of this talk is really
about how the system works how the
architecture enables interactive
exploratory analytics and we start off
with the storage format so this is some
raw data this might be data that's found
in online advertising for example you
have a timestamp of when some ad was
looked at you have a domain where that
ad was displayed you have a gender of a
person looking at the ad and then you
have this metric here which is do they
click on the ad or not the way that grid
works the first thing it does is it's a
process called summarization or roll-up
and the idea is if we could lose some
information about time but preserve the
fidelity of the rest of our data there's
a lot of storage savings that we could
potentially gain so in this example we
have events occurring at some precise
millisecond in time and we might have
billions or trillions of these events
and for most people when you have a
billion or a trillion events you don't
really care about what happened a single
event at a precise millisecond in time
or you care a lot about a lot more is
what occurred over an hour or over a day
so what druid does is it basically can
truncate or optionally truncate the
timestamp to some given granularity
whether that's our minute whatever in
this case in this example is just an
hour and then we look for all
commonalities in these attributes for
example if we truncated these these two
rows or these three rows here to an hour
timestamp you'll notice that the domain
and gender dimensions have the exact
same values and we can just actually
aggregate this click metric together so
it's kind of color coded in this example
here to showcase how roll-up can impact
your raw data and in practice when we
start doing this the data you end up
storing when you start rolling it up can
be about a hundred times less than your
actual raw data and that's significant
storage savings and performance
improvements
so the next thing that your does with
this data is that it partitions it and
it partitions it based on a time value
Lera T so druid does special provisions
to deal with time in this example
basically we have four rolled up events
spread across three separate hours and
then we create three separate partitions
these partitions are called segments and
druid where each partition is containing
hours worth of data so in practice a
segment in druid might have millions of
rows in this example obviously only has
one or two these segments these shards
or these partitions there are very
fundamental concept within druid they
are designed to be immutable which just
means that once a segment is created it
cannot be edited and what that gives us
is it gives us no contention between
reads and writes so a system that has to
handle both reads and writes is going to
have to deal with a lot of different
types of consistency issues and then
resource contention issues in this
example once you create a segment it's
pretty much designed to be read really
really fast and that's all a segments
really about intrudes paralyzation model
you have one CPU or really one core scan
one segment at a time so when you want
to scan a whole lot of data in parallel
you just need a lot of CPUs in your
cluster and this is the reason why druid
is a distributed system as I mentioned
druid is a column store so it stores
every single column individually in this
example I have sample data basically
from Wikipedia edits and we're going to
look at two dimensions here one is
called page the page being edited and
then what's called language the language
of the page so one of the first things
that druid does is a compression or
encoding algorithm called dictionary
encoding and what that means is you have
these variable length strings that
represent pages in this case Justin
Bieber in Kesha as opposed to storing
these strings exactly as is we can map
each of these strings to an integer ID
so Justin Bieber in this case
maps to an ID of zero Kesha maps to an
ID of one and we actually go and store
the page column we actually just end up
storing an array of zeros and ones and
we maintain a dictionary of what a
string value is compared to its integer
representation what's nice about this is
you now store fixed-length integers
which are much easier to compress the
way that druid does filters very very
quickly so as you start zooming in on
your data the way can it can support
that very quickly is we borrowed some
ideas from search infrastructure the
idea here is we look at this page column
we have two values Justin Bieber and
Ke$ha again we can create some sort of
lookup which tells us which rows a
particular value is seen in so imagine
we have six rows of data Justin Bieber
occurs in row 0 1 & 2
Ke$ha appears in rows 3 4 & 5 and the
idea is we can create a binary array
where one indicates the value exists and
0 indicates it doesn't what's nice about
this is if a query came in and said you
know return to me all the characters
added where page is equal to Justin
Bieber we don't need to scan all of our
data what happens is we only scan the
first three rows of data here based on
our our boolean lookup and this is the
process known as basically creating an
inverted index which is an idea found in
a lot of search systems when you do more
complex filters like I want to filter on
Justin Bieber or Ke$ha then you create
you can do a boolean or' of these two
binary arrays which is a very fast
operation and then you get this new
array which is telling you the rows
exact rows you have to scan that match
your initial query predicate and these
boolean array is these binary rays are
very very easy to compress as well
- it is an open-source system and
because it's open-source there's a lot
of capabilities for plugging in your own
components computations and and various
other things one popular way this has
been leveraged is people have built
their own aggregations their own
calculations and kind of just drop them
into Druid example this of this include
account distinct sort of every database
has this nowadays they do count this
think through an algorithm called hyper
log log which is approximating a number
of unique elements in a set
drue can also approximate histograms it
can approximate more more complex
interactions of sets so you can ask
questions like how many unique users
tried product a and also tried product B
but not try products see what else
trying actual any information about the
user names themselves so we can do
ninety-eight ninety-nine percent
accuracy with a lot of different types
of algorithms and you can do them very
very quickly through approximation so
kind of going into the architecture of
the system this is a very high level
architecture how the system really works
is there's a different set of processes
and each set of processes is designed to
do a small set of things very very well
the way that the system is constructed
is the way you load data is either
through a stream of data like from Kafka
or flank or spark or ever or you can
load static files data from files and
streams basically get streamed to a set
of processes called indexers and these
indexers are responsible for converting
raw data and to druids column segment
format i that i just talked about once a
segment is created it is loaded across a
set of processes called historical the
reason why these things are called
historicals is if you have a stream of
data usually the most recent data is on
these indexers and by the time a segment
has been created an hour may have passed
so these these guys
are really just dealing with data that's
older than an hour these guys are
dealing with very recent incoming data
on top of the indexers and historical z'
we have a set of brokers and these guys
they're there
their job is to understand where data
lives and once they receive a query for
that query down to where data lives
druid is a system where compute and
storage are very heavily bundled
together so computation is done right
where the data is stored when you put it
all together you might have a stream of
data coming in these indexers are fully
queryable these historical czar also
queryable so the broker creates this
unified view of what's happening right
now with what's up with what has
happened potentially years in the past
and you have this view of your data
that's recent incoming and also
historical querying you can query data
through JSON or HCP sequel or Python and
Ruby there's a whole lot of different
types of libraries out there in terms of
you is there's a bunch of different UIs
as well I think there's there's a talk
either earlier in this conference or
maybe today around Airbnb a superset
that's a UI those designed initially for
the system
there's pivot which is a UI I just
demoed in the very beginning and there's
other open-source UI's called meta base
and there's a few others as well kind of
by the numbers of how the system
actually works in production truly can
ingest about 500,000 events per second
in some of the largest clusters we've
seen that's just about average it does
three to five million events per second
at peak as sort of the largest volumes
I've seen and comes out to be about 10
to a hundred thousand events per second
per quart some larger clusters they're
handling about I take somewhere between
50 to 100 petabytes of raw data with
somewhere between 50 to 100 trillion
events all that data compresses down to
about 500 terabytes of segments queries
over this data about half a second
average core latency with about 99%
completing in less than 10 seconds
so kind of go into the last section here
common use cases people have found of
this system one is around dirty is used
in production I think by a few hundred
if not a few thousand companies at this
point it is used for a variety of
different use cases both popular being
one is around user activity this is
being able to understand how users are
interacting with your product with your
system you can group users or around any
ad-hoc set of attributes with no sort of
prior pre-computation or pre definition
you can compare one group of users with
one set of attributes against another
group of users with another set of
attributes and then be able to define
ad-hoc interesting groupings do top
lists and count the number of unique
users matching any arbitrary set of
criteria another popular use case this
system is a marketplace data this is
really anything involving revenue or
finance as a metric here a very popular
use case is trying to understand if
there's a spike or dip in revenue and
then try to understand what is causing
that another popular use case is doing
an arbitrary grouping of things such as
a product definition or a user
definition and then doing deeper
analysis of how that product or user is
is performing with sort of any event
oriented data store devops is a popular
use case this is just your standard
tracking millions of different time
series and nice use case here is the ad
hoc nature of being able to understand
your system metrics so you can group you
know all certain types of servers all
arbitrary like API calls all services in
Iraq or in a datacenter
and so on and so forth very last section
here is just about how this system is
typically used in the wild
the most common architecture sort of end
to end architecture I've seen is one
where events are first fed to some sort
of message bus and then they are
processed either through a stream
processor or batch processor and
infected Roo it
there might be a sequel Hadoop layer
actually that's on top oh dude that
pulls data from druid and crunches
numbers for message bus Apache Kafka is
very very popular here for a stream
processor flank spark Sansa storm
there's many stream processors for batch
processors there's things like just
standard vanilla MapReduce in Hadoop or
spark to batch process the data and load
into druid good is designed to work with
a whole lot of different other systems
in the whole big data ecosystem works
well with kafka hadoop in a lot of
different systems that start with the
letter S so you can you can download
this as I mentioned it's open source you
can get it from the project webpage you
can get it from our web page as well
it's under the Apache 2 license you can
download and play with it if you're if
you're interested or have some of these
problems I described and yeah in summary
I think through it is a pretty cool alec
system it there was a large history
before we reach the architecture and I
hope you got something useful at the
talk thanks everyone thank you Fang Jean
and now we'd get questions
thank you is really impressed talk today
and will help two questions the first
Detroit hi the columnar orientation
based so does any means it will be very
expensive to join the to the source and
secondly it will be designer needs the
user the rubric a notable case either a
voter from the rubric inaudible virtual
career against joy sorry was the second
question
they didn't be able to connect you to
Jupiter no the book okay
so around the first question because
it's a column orientation how expensive
are the joints so I definitely think
there is a system that targeted towards
like very interactive workflows so it's
joint support is basically limited right
now to like broadcast joints so if you
join like a large table with a very
small table and that small table can be
replicated across the entire entire
cluster that one is done very very
quickly if you want to join like a
billion row table and a billion row
table we don't really know the way that
can be done interactively like that's
going to take order of minutes or tens
of minutes as usually the case and druid
has very limited support for that right
now we're adding support for it but even
then it's going to be a very non
interactive workflow I don't know how to
make large table joins very fast or if
any system that doesn't very fast but if
you know the way and I love to love to
learn more about it with regards to the
second question and try to remember what
the second question was I'm actually
having a mind blank
it was around Jupiter notebooks yes
thank you too for notebooks I'm actually
not sure if this but did you for their
notebooks sport sequel they do you know
what this support is for do for
notebooks in sequel
okay so I have limited experience but
someone the audience just mentioned that
Druids Python library should be able to
interface with duper notebooks I was
going to say that druid sequel interface
can hurt and can interact with or can
work with most like BI tools that speak
sequel like Pablo and looker and others
but I don't have that much experience
with - for notebooks but folks the
audience might know my actually know
more so we have I think three more
people so yeah these person can freak
[Applause]
sorry Donna yeah I just want to echo
your comments so this is a really
awesome talk and really appreciate it
thank you I just wanted to learn a
little bit more about the details around
the summarization tables and when those
happen in terms of storing data on disk
and maybe that's related to the indexes
versus historical I'm just trying to
understand conceptually when do you have
atomic data on disk versus when do these
roll-ups happen into higher grain tables
so these roll-ups are optional the way
that data ingestion works in Druid is
you submit a JSON blob kind of telling
it I want to ingest data from like this
in this source here's kind of the rough
schema of my data and then here's a
rollup to potentially apply if you do
choose to do some of this pre
aggregation it happens immediately as
data is being ingested into the system
so when you turn roll-up on then your
raw data information is going to be lost
and instead through it is going to be
storing a summarized version of your
data like right away got it and I assume
between like the index and historical
tables that data is sort of an atomic
grain in the in the index ones and then
since you said the historical ones are
immutable
like once you Aggron AG and those like
you you basically lose the atomic yeah
so what happens through this process I
didn't go into full detail about it but
there's these guys they do the support
both read and write functionality and
these guys support read-only
functionality the read and write
functionality the way it works
is as data is being streamed in there's
a right optimize data structure that's
designed such that rights can happen as
fast as possible and that's basically
just a key value store in memory so as
data is being streamed in it's not going
to be complete it's not going to be
converted into a column orientation
right away it's going to be stored in
this intermediate key value memory
storage and none of the indexes get
created and we're kind of rely on the
fact that one it's a small amount of
data and the second that it's entirely a
memory for fast performance periodically
what actually happens behind the scenes
is that that in memory buffer gets
flushed and like a tiny mini segment
gets created and this mini segment is
the sort of readout my structure so this
is constant conversion process between
the right optimized piece and our read
optimize piece and once that conversion
happens there's a bunch of mini segments
that get generated they all get merged
together into the spinal a mutable
segment that's then handed off so
there's this yeah there's this constant
flow of recent incoming data that goes
through many different stages before it
reaches the final segment format got it
thank you very much next question thank
you very much for this talk and I'm just
wondering in the best but in this case
what would be the optimal solution
should mean Stella do it on a separate
cluster can we can it be integrated into
jar and Hadoop and so on and so on so
yeah that's a actually very good
question because druid is composed of
different types of processes you can
actually find like different types of
processes can have different resource
requirements so what people have done is
they might have dedicated hardware for
some of the processes like historical if
you have a lot of data on them and
they're doing a lot of like parallel
reads people have allocated kind of
dedicated hardware and dedicated
resources for that for the indexers if
you're just having a small volume data
being ingested you might not need all
the resources in machine and people have
actually just run those on yarn it's it
really varies in the wall how people run
things I've known entire cluster to run
on me so I've known part of a cluster
running on dedicated hardware and part
of a cluster kind of running on your
so it's a mixture and it really depends
on kind of what your data volumes are
where your query volumes look like